[Music]
YouTube how to's building a presence on
YouTube is like fine-tuning the engine
of a car to get maximum performance in
YouTube terms this means maximum views
and maximum subscribers to your YouTube
channel the instruments you have for
this are the video itself how you
optimize it in YouTube and the quality
of the YouTube channel you create to
promote your YouTube presence if you do
get maximum performance out of your
YouTube presence YouTube will reward you
by giving you the opportunity to
monetize your YouTube videos through the
YouTube advertising platforms by the end
of this lesson you will know how to use
the new YouTube studio beta how to
upload and optimize a YouTube video how
to create and optimize a YouTube channel
how to create a playlist on your YouTube
channel
how to make a great video and how to
monetize your YouTube presence YouTube
has just launched the new YouTube studio
beta
most of the YouTube features like
uploading and optimizing your videos
have been brought into the new YouTube
studio beta some of the features like
creating your YouTube channel still need
to be accessed through the old version
of YouTube studio soon these features
will be brought into the new version
which will make the old version obsolete
when you are successful in YouTube in
views and subscribers YouTube will give
you the opportunity to monetize your
YouTube presence upload video on desktop
to upload a video on YouTube you can do
that on the desktop and you can also do
that on the mobile let's have a look at
the desktop version of uploading your
video so what you do is you go to the
youtube.com homepage and as long as
you're logged into your Google account
you see your little login account info
here you will then see on the left a
little camera with a plus sign and
that's where you can upload a video
click on that you can then upload your
video or you can go live streaming so
let's click on upload video and that
takes you to this screen where you can
select a file to upload or you can drag
and drop the video file you can
immediately add the settings for
published public unlisted private or you
can schedule the video you can also
import videos from your google photos
drive you can start life streaming from
here as well
and there is a new feature which is
called premiere this is where you can
schedule a video and invite your
followers to watch the video together
with you and when the schedule dates is
there the video goes public on YouTube
and you can watch it together on a
premier screen so what I'm going to do
is to select the file to upload I just
click on the finder and then I can drag
the video file here in the box
and while it is uploading I can enter
basic info of the video in this case I
will call it flower garden in Malaysia
you can then give a description you can
set tags so when the processing of the
video is complete you can pick your
thumbnail and then you click publish and
you will see that the video is live on
YouTube so let's select set the
thumbnail you can see that the
processing is done and here I click to
publish the video is now live so if I
click here on the link it will actually
take me to the video and there is my
video on YouTube the flower garden in
Malaysia
upload video on mobile to upload a video
through your mobile you have to use the
YouTube mobile app once you start a
mobile app you will see it top the
little video icon when I click on that
icon there are various options you can
choose from
I can click record if I want to create a
video that I want to upload I can click
on go life that takes me straight into
the live streaming of my video or I can
select a video from the video library on
my phone so for this demo I will click
on select a video and then I can select
a video that I want to upload there are
some basic editing functions I have on
the video I'll show that in a later demo
and if I want to select this video I
click on next and as we saw with the
desktop demo I can add the name and the
description of the video and I can then
upload the video on YouTube
you
the video is now uploaded so once the
video is ready you will see it in the
list of the video and then obviously you
can go into the edit mode to add more
details in the title or in the
description and optimize your video so
now you see that the video is uploaded
to my list of videos on YouTube and you
can also see it's just placed above the
video that I just upload it through the
desktop version of YouTube YouTube
studio better YouTube has come up with a
new version of the interface to manage
your videos on YouTube it's called
YouTube studio Banta
not all the features have moved to the
new version for those features that
haven't migrated yet YouTube will but
direct you to the old version of the
interface or if you prefer the old
interface YouTube will still give you
the option to switch back to it but like
they do with migrations to new
interfaces after a few months they will
switch the option to move back off the
new interface is very simple to use let
me show you the desktop version of it
and then I will show you the mobile app
for it to access YouTube creator studio
better you have to be logged into your
Google account and when you're on the
youtube.com homepage you click on your
little photo here on the right and then
you click on YouTube studio beta that
will take you to the YouTube studio
better dashboards
what you see here at the bottom left is
creator studio classic so you can still
switch back to the classic format of the
creator studio and again if you want to
switch back to the studio beta you click
here on creator studio beta to go back
to the new interface there are still a
few features like creating playlists
translations transcriptions that sit in
the old version when you select those
you will go back to creator studio
classic so what's there to see on the
dashboard first of all you have your
latest video that you upload it with
some basic information you can go to the
video analytics of this particular video
and the see comments you also get a list
of your channel analytics highlights it
gives you a link to your channel
analytics and your top videos of the
last two hours
and then here you see content that
YouTube presents like YouTube news and
information about creator insider here
they give you additional videos where
you can learn about how to use YouTube
it will also show you some ideas on how
to improve your channel or in this case
help navigating the new interface
here on the left you have your main menu
you can go into your videos analytics
check out commands go to the
transcriptions of your videos and other
features and then down here you have
your settings and link back to the
creator studio classic so if we click
here on videos you have a list of all
the videos that you have uploaded on
YouTube it's much friendlier and much
better accessible than in the old
creator studio classic so here you see
the two videos that we've just uploaded
and then here you see what is the
visibility of the video and the date
that you published it
you'll also see how many fuse how many
comments and how many likes or dislikes
a really good new feature here is the
inline editing as we call this if I want
to quickly change the title or the
description of this video I don't have
to open the video and click on edit I
can actually click it here I can
actually change it here in lime so
there's a few things I can do in line
edit a title and the description get a
link promote for advertising download or
delete a video
so if I say edit title and description
and add in Cotswolds and then in here
I'm just clicking and then I'm just
clicking save and you see it will
automatically change the title so this
is a very easy and convenient new
feature I can click here and see the
video directly on YouTube as well and
here you see the analytics so when you
click on analytics it takes you to the
general overview of the analytics where
you can see what's the activity and
what's the views that we got in our
channel what are the top videos that
people are watching what is the
real-time activity happening on your
videos and then you can see here about
the viewers the interest of the viewers
the built-in audience and how to earn
revenue so we'll get back into the
analytics later but at least here you
have an idea of what you can get from
the analytics you can then check out the
comments that you had on the various
video you can look at the transcription
files that you've had for your videos
and which ones have been published and
then it takes you to your other features
as well
in the settings you can set things like
the currency that you're using what your
default experience is for the classic or
for the new YouTube studio beta you can
have your channel settings like the name
of your channel the keywords for your
channel and the country for your channel
you can check on your community you can
add filters you can look at the
moderators and approved users that you
can add and you can look at other
settings like your advanced channel
settings or channel branding
but you will access these through the
Creator studio classic so this gives you
a short overview of the Creator studio
bathtub using YouTube studio on a mobile
to access YouTube studio on your mobile
you have to download a mobile app and
then when you open the mobile app you
could almost like a similar experiences
on the desktop it starts with your
dashboards this gives you an overview of
your analytics of the last 28 days the
last videos that you upload it the last
comments that you received and the total
number of subscribers you have to your
channel to access the menu you tap on
the hamburger button on the top left and
this gives you a similar list of options
that you have for the desktop version
you can go to your videos you can check
your playlists check the commands go to
your analytics and change your YouTube
settings when I click on videos it gives
you a list of all the videos that you
uploaded for each video you see the
number of views the number of commands
the number of likes the number of
dislikes you can sort the videos by most
recent most viewed and you can look at
all the videos you can filter by Draft
by public unlisted and private video the
few from your mobile is very easy and
it's simple to browse through all the
videos that you've uploaded on your
mobile you can look at your playlist and
make some changes to your playlist and
then you can also check the comments on
the videos if you click on analytics you
get more detailed stats about your
videos you can see your overview any
revenue that you would have made you can
look at analytics for your playlist and
it also gives you analytics of any
interactive content that you have used
in your videos like click throughs or
cards let's go back to the dashboard to
complete this demo this gives you an
idea of what you can manage through the
YouTube studio app editing a video on
YouTube
now that your video is uploaded
YouTube there are two things that you
may want to do first you may want to
edit the video like trimming the
beginning or the end or adding some
special effects to the video and you
definitely have to optimize the video
for search on both YouTube and Google so
let's have a look at both of these areas
and to start with editing the video
let's take for instance this video here
a video blog that I did a little while
ago if I click on the video it takes me
to the area where I can add the
information to optimize the video and
I'll come back to that later but here
you can click on editor and this takes
me to a full screen video editing mode
it's a very basic video editing so it
doesn't give you all the functionality
like for instance iMovie or Adobe
Premiere but it does two thing for you
if you want to make some quick changes
to the video you can trim the video you
can add music or play with the sound of
the video you can add an end screen to
the video and you could blur faces for
instance on the video these are basic
functions but they work really well
let's have a look first at the sound if
I click here on audio and I open the
audio library that YouTube has it gives
you a full library of royalty free music
tracks that you can add to your video so
for instance I can select here the noise
I can add that to my video when it's too
loud you have a slider where you can say
favorites to the original audio so now
you hear my voice in the background in
today's video blog let's go back now and
close this
you can also add an end screen to the
video and there are a number of
templates you can choose from an and
screen will show during the last 20
seconds of the video you can show a
playlist or a subscribe button or you
can have reference to two different
videos or two videos or playlists so
different formats that you can choose
from let's pick the two video templates
when I click on apply then here you
would see how that will show in the last
20 seconds of the video when I play the
video you see that I haven't added any
video but this is how it would show as
an end screen in your video and then you
can add blur to a video as well you can
blur faces or you can blur specific
areas in your video this is all I will
be showing you on editing your video as
I said before it's a basic video editor
but if you want to do some quick editing
on your video before you publish it then
this is a really good tool to do just
that optimizing a video in YouTube
studio so the next thing you want to do
is to optimize your video for youtube
search and for Google search so how do
you go about it when you select a video
let's take this one epic fail
how to ruin your life on an easyJet
flight you click on the video and that
takes you to the basic optimization
screen there are a few things that are
important here first of all the title
this title epic fail how to ruin your
life on an easyJet flight is an
interesting title it tells people
there's something happening here it's
very important to use a word like epic
fail people like seeing videos with epic
fails
so remember title is extremely important
there are two reasons why people decide
to watch your video on YouTube number
one is the title number two is the
thumbnail and that's the next thing you
want to optimize YouTube will pick a few
thumbnails based on your video but you
can also upload
your own thumbnail the third part is
also important the description of your
video it's important that the
description of the video is in line with
the title and what the viewer is going
to see make sure you use keywords that
are relevant to the video and to your
business and here you can add tags tags
are key for the search it helps people
to find your video based on the tags
that you've set
here you can see the public URL of your
video and here you can decide on the
visibility of your video do you want
your video to be public private or
unlisted unlisted video will be public
but they won't show up in the search
here you can select the playlist that
you want the video to be part of you can
assign a video to the various playlists
that you have on your channel this is
where you can create cards and the end
screen in the video editing demo we
looked at how you can add and streams
and how you can add video cards to your
video if you click on it then you see
the editing mode and here are the
different types of cards that you can
add like a video or a playlist or a
channel or you could even create a poll
where you encourage viewers to
participate
so you just click on the create and then
you can pick a video from the list that
shows up that video will actually show
up and then here you see where the video
card will appear
so if we go to the beginning of the
video and we would click play then here
you see two suggested video popping up
so you can now save the changes and go
back to the editor
so these are the basic settings for the
optimization of your video and you can
also go to the Advanced Settings there's
a lot more that you can add in the
Advanced Settings you can add the
recording date the location of the video
and you can also add the lysis and write
ownership of the video if you are part
of the commercial network with YouTube
you can select a syndication where you
want your videos to show you can select
a category for your video the language
and the caption certification when there
may be television FCC regulations
regarding closed captions you can also
upload your subtitles and closed
captioning YouTube will actually create
subtitles for you and then you can check
that later it is not 100% accurate but
at least it's a good starting point for
your subtitles finally you can set
things like allowing comments and
ratings and enabling age restrictions as
well you can allow people to embed the
video and you can also take whether the
video contains pay promotion like
product placement sponsorships or
endorsements
so lots of things that you can set in
the optimization and when you're happy
with it you just click Save Google and
YouTube will then include all these
settings in the indexing of the video
and the better you do all this the more
likely your video will show up in the
search so let's go to Google and check
this epic fail video we have a good
thumbnail and a good title if you go to
Google and search for epic fail easyJet
for instance then you see that the video
immediately shows up here in Google and
that's obviously what you want for your
videos
you want them to show up high in the
videos or in the image section of the
search results page and if you do the
same search in YouTube then you would
like your video to show up as well and
you see here immediately it shows up as
the first video so this is all there is
to optimizing your video another
important part and we briefly touched on
this are the subtitles and the
transcriptions that you may want to add
to your video first you want to check if
YouTube created transcriptions for your
video take this video blog for example
if I select other futures you see here
translation and transcription the
automated transcription from YouTube has
not been brought into the new studio
beta so we need to go to the old studio
of Nucci
so I click here on the old classic
creator studio translation and
transcription and then here you see the
link to the published transcript file I
haven't put it in this is something that
YouTube will do when it's a video that's
worth transcribing you could copy the
text so you can download it and then use
that for a blog post or for the show
notes of your podcast you can also add
language and you can set the
transcription on published or draft very
useful features and very important to
make sure that your video is optimized
creating a YouTube channel to create a
YouTube channel you have to go to your
YouTube home page and then you click on
little photo here that you will see when
you locked into your Google account
and you click on the settings it will
take you to the screen where you will be
able to click on the button see all my
channels or create a new channel so
let's click on this and now you will see
the screen where you can enter the name
of your channel and in this case I'm
going to call it react for Russia I
click create and you will then get to
the page where you can start customizing
your channel
if I click on customize channel I see
the blank version of the YouTube channel
where you can add your logo your channel
art and where you can add a channel
description so let's start with adding a
short channel description
welcome to my youtube channel of rear
fascia
when we're done with that we can add the
logo to do that you click on the little
pencil icon it will actually take you to
the brand page of your Google account
click on edit and you can upload a photo
click on upload photo and here we are
going to upload this image
once it has uploaded the photo you can
play a bit with the size of it
you can move it up a bit if you want so
I'm going to move it so I only show the
mosaic
I click done and then my brand page has
been updated with the image
if I now go back to the YouTube page and
I do a refresh you will see that the
image has been added to the YouTube page
I can do the same for the channel art
click on the channel art you need to be
aware that you don't have a lot of space
to play with for your image so you need
to make sure that you have a horizontal
photo that will show enough of what you
want to cover in the banner
you
a nice feature is that it will show you
how it will look on the desktop how it
will look on the TV and how it will look
on the mobile and if you're not happy
with it you can adjust the crop a little
so I can zoom in and then move it up
so at least I see a little bit of the
mountains and a bit of the mosque on the
photo when I'm happy with it
I click select and then you will see
that you have uploaded the banner and
you are now ready to start optimizing
your YouTube channel
checking the YouTube channel settings so
the first thing you want to check when
you start optimizing your channel is
your settings of the channel you can
access the channel settings by clicking
on the little car drill on the top right
click on that and this will take you to
the basic privacy settings you can keep
your videos private subscriptions
private your saved playlists private you
can customize the layout of your channel
and you can show the discussion tab so
you can basically switch all these
options on or off and you can also
translate your channel info the basic
settings you can find on this little
screen but there are more options in the
account settings and in the Advanced
Settings so let's look first at the
options in the account settings this is
where you can look at what you're going
to share on YouTube you can look at your
connected apps for instance in this
section do you want any other apps to
connect with your YouTube you can also
set how to connect your TV to the
YouTube channel you can connect your
YouTube to a particular TV device and
you can look at your Billings and
payments and your playback and
performance this is where you can
control your video experience you can
show annotations and in video
notifications you can also said that the
captions are always on or when that's
available show automatic captions by
speech recognition you can also set the
notifications for your YouTube so you
can receive emails about your activities
if you want updates from YouTube or
notifications around channel
subscriptions and other notifications
like recommended videos if I go back to
the main channel page and I'm going back
into the settings I can then also go
into the advanced settings for my
channel in the advanced settings
can check the country that I'm based I
can set keywords for my channels I can
disable interest-based ads and I can
link my AdWords account I can activate
channel recommendations and displayed a
subscriber account this is also where
you can integrate your YouTube channel
with your Google Analytics so look a bit
further up here I can see the branding
options that I have so I can add a
watermark to my channel videos I can
also set defaults for uploading my
videos this can be quite handy if you
have standard text that you want to use
for every video and I can set some
standard tags for instance this can be
helpful when you upload lots of videos
so the standard defaults are already set
and then finally here you see the status
and features of your channel this is
where you have all the different options
that you have with your channel and you
can check what the status is the
different elements that are enabled and
elements that you are eligible for and
the elements that you are ineligible for
for example we're not eligible for
monetization because we haven't signed
up for it and we haven't passed two
requirements for this so for all these
things we can see whether we have it
enabled whether we are eligible or
whether we are ineligible and that's all
there is to the settings so let's go
back now to the channel by clicking on
the logo and we can then start looking
at the optimization of our channel how
to optimize your YouTube channel to
start customization and optimization of
a YouTube channel you have to go to the
standard channel page and click
customise channel
here you see the structure and elements
of your YouTube channel an important
feature is that you can look at your
channel as yourself as a new visitor or
as a returning visitor you can set a
video at the top of your YouTube channel
which will change whether you're a new
visitor or a returning visitor
but let's first look at the different
elements of new YouTube page that you
can change you can add videos to your
channel you can add playlists to your
channel and you can connect with other
channels you can manage your discussions
and you can put more improving your
About section this is also where you can
link to your other social media pages
these will show on your channel banner
and you can feature other channels that
you would like to promote on your
YouTube channel so you start with adding
some videos to your channel click on
videos and you see this channel has no
video yet remember how we upload the
video in youtube by clicking this little
plus icon and we say upload video we can
then select a video that we want to
upload
let's take this short video add some
basing settings and set some tags
you
once the video is processed you can then
publish it on your channel page
and if you go back to your channel
we'll see that the video has been added
so that's how you can upload videos to
your channel you can then look at
playlists here you can add a playlist to
your channel a playlist is a group of
videos around a particular topic and
then you can feature those playlists as
chapters in your YouTube channel it
makes it very easy to organize your
videos to create a playlist I click on
new playlist I give it a title marrakesh
in this case
and that if I click create and then your
playlist has been created then you need
to add videos to your playlist if you go
back to the video and play it to get
into editing mode then in the settings
of the video I can say to which playlist
I want to add this video
I select a playlist that I just created
and click done and I save it and then I
have added a video to my playlist
so if i now go back to my youtube
channel i can click on playlists and
there is my marrakech playlist and it
currently has one video
I can add channels so I can link to any
other channel I may have
I can manage my discussions and I can
manage my about page in this section as
well I can activate business inquiries
so people can send me an email through
my channel
I can specify my location and I can add
my social media links you will then show
up in my youtube channel banner you can
also add featured channels for instance
I want to add the social media examiner
YouTube channel I can add that and I can
click done and then it will show in the
featured channels
if I'm happy with the settings I can go
back to my channel and then you see what
we've done to the channel right now
we've got our first video we have our
featured channel and we have our
playlist
you
so this is how I can optimize my youtube
channel one more thing I would like to
show you if I click customize channel
then I can see here the featured content
which will show up on the channel for
either returning visitors or new
visitors
if I click here on feature content and
then I pick for instance the video that
I just uploaded then this is how it will
show
I can add a heading for this content so
for example I can say future
presentation and I click Save
and now you see I have a feature video
for the returning visitors I can also do
this for new visitors I can create a
channel trailer for instance I pick this
video and then I click Save and that's
how it will show for new visitors so
these are the basic things you need to
look at when you want to optimize your
YouTube channel
YouTube channel views and subscribers
now that we know how to edit and
optimize your videos and your YouTube
channel we will turn our attention to
how to grow views and subscribers on
your channel first there is your channel
optimize your channel page write a
compelling channel description use a
great channel logo and a banner and
create a channel tagline then there are
your videos make an awesome channel
trailer video publish long videos of 10
minutes and more promote videos in your
end screen add a branded watermark and
add a subscribe button and enter videos
with a strong call-to-action thirdly
there is your channel management reply
to every comment and heart great
contents and finally promote your
channel embed YouTube videos in blog
posts and promote your channel in ebooks
webinars presentations and lead magnets
doing all these things right will
certainly help you in growing views and
subscriptions to your channel tube buddy
is a great tool that can help you in
growing your video views and your
channel subscriptions
it's a grown browser extension and it
adds a layer of functionality on top of
your YouTube channel it has features
that focus on SEO promotion and
analytics and it also tracks the video
rankings of your videos but also the
videos of your competitors it's a great
tool to find keywords for your videos
and you can go to your competitor video
and check what tags they have set and
use these as keywords for your videos it
also helps you in publishing videos on
your channel you can schedule videos to
be published and added to playlists you
can make bulk updates to your videos
including the descriptions and it also
helps you to create eye-catching
thumbnails
factors that make a great video of
course it's not only the optimization of
the video that makes the video
successful it is also about a video
itself done well you can use your iPhone
to make highly professional cinema
quality videos that are being watched by
millions as unsane a feature movie from
film director Steven Soderbergh proved
let me give you some tips how to make
great video think about composition
point of view and lighting first
composition is about how you place the
different elements in the scene put some
thought into this use the rule of thirds
and focus on people's eyes I'll explain
the rule of thirds shortly point of view
is the angle you are using of the lens
of the camera in relation to the subject
be creative with this use a low angle or
a high angle and change these regularly
lighting can make the difference to a
good or a bad video always be aware of
your light source and also know that
daylight is the best light source there
is but different times during the day
can give different shadow effects in the
video for instance noon sunlight creates
unflattering shadows whereas a cloudy
day can produce more softer lights using
the right equipment is also very
important in shooting great videos
obviously your phone can fulfill most of
the camera requirements like shooting
video and recording sounds and it will
give you an acceptable level of quality
make sure the resolution settings on
your phone are on 4k or 1080 HD and it's
set at 24 30 or 60 frames per second
avoid zooming avoid BEC lights and use
both hands if you want to up the quality
to professional then you may want to use
a high quality DSLR camera an additional
gear like a tripod and a microphone the
road level air microphone is a great mic
that you can attach to your iPhone and
your color it gives excellent quality
sound and you can overlay that sound
over the sound file of
your video earlier I promised you I was
going to explain the rule of thirds they
are part of the basic rules of
composition the rule of thirds is a
compositional rule that suggests
dividing the image into thirds and
placing the subject on one of those
sides instead of in the center it is one
of the most important composition
techniques used by professional
photographers but there are others as
well for instance using balance and
symmetry in your video or apply leading
lines in your video these lines direct a
viewer to a particular section of the
screen finally as I mentioned before a
simple rule is to focus on the eye it
gives a point of focus monetizing your
YouTube channel there are various ways
that you can make money with YouTube but
it depends on how strong your subscriber
bases and how many views you get on your
channel if you are qualified then you
can participate in Google's Adsense
program which means that you can get
revenue from ads being placed before or
during your videos when people watch
them
this works very well and many publishers
on YouTube can a significant revenue
stream through this channel you can also
try to get sponsorships for your channel
this can take the form of brand or
product sponsorship for which you will
get paid you can also look into
affiliate marketing with this you can
advertise products from your affiliate
partners on your channel and you would
get a percentage of the sales that comes
in through your channel and finally if
people like your videos then they may
Commission you to make videos for them
as I mentioned before you need to have a
strong channel to qualify for Google's
Adsense program which means you need to
have at least 4,000 watch hours in the
previous 12 months and 1000 subscribers
to sign up for Adsense you need to go to
the old version of creative studio and
click on channel and monetization you
can set the monetization preferences and
which video you want to run the ads with
if you qualify Google will then approve
your request and you are ready to start
earning money with YouTube here are the
key takeaways of this lesson
YouTube has recently launched a new
version of YouTube studio called YouTube
studio beta getting fuse and subscribers
on your YouTube channel is based on your
video the quality and optimization of
your channel and how you promote your
channel composition lighting and point
of view are important contributors to
the quality of your video and you can
make money with YouTube through
advertising sponsorships and
commissioned work
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here